E aí
[Música]
e eu pensava muito sobre esse lugar que
o empreendedorismo conquistou na nossa
sociedade né e antes de mais nada
enquanto a gente se por Será que o Paulo
vai falar mal de empreendedorismo quando
o empreendedorismo e inovação são tão
importantes né é eu não tenho nada
contra empreendedorismo muito pelo
contrário muito menos pelos empregadores
Mas a gente pode interpretar e observar
os fenômenos e observar como é que a
zona em sociais se estabelece é de
diferentes formas e e eu gosto de ter
sempre um ponto de vista crítico que não
precisa ser a verdade mas é uma
interpretação tá E para essa
interpretação a gente tem que fazer
alguns recortes o primeiro deles é que
quando eu tô falando do Empreendedor eu
não tô falando de todo empreendedor todo
o ser
e eu tô falando de sobretudo dos
empreendedores de base tecnológica
é o do universo da sapatos por exemplo e
que infelizmente a gente também tem um
recorte e um viés de gênero de raça e é
isso é uma Persona muito clara de quem
que é esse empreendedor né um homem
branco hétero educado de escola
particular teve atualmente universidade
pública que faz beleza enfim classe
média alta é e que não necessariamente
representa a classe trabalhadora
brasileira mas sim se tornou de alguma
forma é um representante de uma ideal
dessa Nova Ordem do trabalho né que
estabeleceu aí nos últimos mais ou menos
dez cinco a dez anos é por aqui fora do
Brasil um pouco antes essa história ela
começa Porque toda geral
e ela cria uma espécie de paradigma de
um sucesso profissional né na geração
dos meus pais por exemplo o sucesso
profissional era o concurso público ou
trabalhar nessas grandes empreiteiros
nas grandes obras de infraestrutura do
país tem o frio né assim Engenheiro
médico e advogado que eram as posições
de valor depois na minha geração sob uma
forte influência de novo dos Estados
Unidos da cultura americana da Sessão da
Tarde quase praticamente assim formando
a nossa geração é de uma forte
influência do mercado financeiro essa
construção do lugar do executivo né do
manager do cio essa cultura do Sucesso
como empresário
e não como um nem como um empresário não
mas como executivo mesmo como alguém que
trabalha para uma grande organização de
gravata Ltda onde aqui às vezes não
necessariamente gravada Claro é mais
usado na década de 80 sim é um
e esse like virou um lugar de sucesso
lugar do desejo né lugar de ser um líder
e uma grande empresa década de 80 90 e
início dos anos2000 Você tem todo uma
uma parada nem todo mundo ideal o senhor
seus programas de Trainee são super
disputados com centenas e milhares de
candidatos para sessão o caminho
acelerado a liderança nesse lugar da
liderança corporativa é passa a ser
disputado inclusive entre as próprias
empresas né vira Quase que o mercado
como é o mercado de atletas de alto
nível do futebol por exemplo porque
começa a acontecer de um competidor vir
roubar um gerente fazer uma proposta
levar um grande executivo se eu daqui
vai para lá e etc é é
há diferenças ficam um pouco expostas a
esse risco de perder as suas mentes
perderam suas vidas cabeças perderam as
suas lideranças então elas capricham no
pacote de Bodas pacote executivos que
tem uma série de regalias etc porque
para elas custam muito caro né
desenvolveram uma pessoa e viver o
dilema do Bonsai né que quando essa
pessoa fica boa eu saio é até por isso
uma das formas que as empresas e quando
eu falo de as empresas gente eu tô
falando de As empresas dos donos dos
negócios dos grandes acionistas dos
detentores do Poder de facto da fonte do
dinheiro tá eu vou falar disso várias
vezes não têm importante pegar quando eu
falo dos donos das ionising vestido
quando a fonte da grana tá é é
a passar na colocar conta contratos de
confidencialidade cláusulas de
confidencialidade e evitar para evitar
um pouco essa pedra da informações
estratégicas então o Executivo era
obrigado a ficar de seis meses a um ano
afastada não no mercado porque senão eu
poderia expor as informações da empresa
enfim é nesse momento inclusive existe a
versão contemporânea corporativa do que
é um ano sabático né quando você ouvir
alguém falar que tá adiando o sabático
nesse sentido específico significa que
essa pessoa está cumprindo uma cláusula
de quarentena de contenciosidade é uma
companhia e quem se aproveitou e cresceu
de uma forma gigantesca nesses momentos
foram as escolas de negócios né ah não
foi a água Business School não a raiva
de mim parece minha raiva mesmo escovar
estampa foi é
o Brasil FGV Nacional Cabral começar uma
ver esses períodos como a oportunidade
de oferecer alguma coisa para que esse
executivo se desenvolvesse desse período
de afastamento inclusive criavam meio de
convivência entre eles não é assim e se
você observar os gráficos de crescimento
nas escolas de negócios e ver que tem
todo uma toda uma cultura né todo mundo
paradinha social mesmo que passa a ser
compartilhado aí né é um outro efeito
dessa dança das cadeiras esse ciclos
aqui com os executivos eles passam a não
ser fidelizar não ficar tanto tempo
dentro das organizações e não sabe
quando a gente vai ficar e na verdade os
bônus são de um ano então você quer
fazer aquilo que vai garantir o seu
bônus do ano você começa a importar
e o ciclo de tomada de decisão significa
que as decisões passam ser cada vez mais
de curto prazo é e a gente sabe que
muitas vezes uma decisão de curto prazo
pode ser boa Pode parecer boa mas é bem
ruim e médio e longo prazo ou pode ser
bem ruim e médio e longo prazo né essa
conta então começa a ficar cara para os
donos do negócio dos donos dos negócios
para os investidores de novo aquela
turma que eu te falei é E aí essa essa
conta que tá cara esse modelo de
trabalho esse paradigma profissional ele
começa a se esgotar e tem um ponto
culminante na crise nela explosão na
crise do mercado financeiro em 2008 nos
Estados Unidos que depois o cartão mundo
inteiro é é claro que a crise não foi
causada por essas questões que eu tô
falando
o tema sofreu e foi influenciada de uma
forma significativa por tudo que eu tô
compartilhando é tão a partir de 2008
empreendedores já existiu status já
existiam Vale do Silício já existia mais
de 2008 para cá Talvez um pouco antes
você já viu uma guinada para essa
construção ideológica de um novo lugar
do trabalho chega a gente precisava né
os donos do negócio investidores as
fontes precisavam de um novo arranjo
Trabalhista de uma nova relação é que
não fosse tão exposta né ou que
mitigasse os principais riscos
me atende então vendidos com essa classe
executiva né E aí era preciso criar
pertencimento criar engajamento e criar
a sensação de independência entre os
hipotensão hipotensão som como são
denominados essas pessoas que eram os
grandes talentos né é o tema era ele
ensinar sempre foi High potential e aí a
melhor forma de você criar pertencimento
engajamento Independência é a
propriedade Ou seja eu crio o ideal de
que se você não talento você não precisa
ficar dentro de uma organização se você
é um talento você deve Inovar você deve
começar algo novo você deve se lançar ao
risco você deve empreender né
e sobretudo porque por você empreende
todo empreendedor de base tecnológica no
fim das contas meio que busca a
validação através de rodadas de
investimento e o sucesso vem do valor e
rodada de investimento etc tudo mais é
cortou você é culpado ou você de fato
recebe as rodadas de investimento para
que seu negócio cresça cada vez mais
aqueles casos né a gente tá fazendo
Startup ele tá falando de modelos
escaladas é esse arranjo de trabalho ele
protege os donos do negócio de uma forma
ele não acaba com todos os riscos É
claro é porque investir também é o risco
é é um risco Grande para quem não sabe
fazer sobretudo É mas o empreendedor não
pede demissão do seu próprio negócio né
Ele é extremamente engajado é esse o
negócio tá errado
E é só foi o processo de fritura é um
empreendedor nunca eu investidor é
raramente você vai revelar um escândalo
algum traço de um grande fracasso se não
aparece os investidores não aparece né
que aparece umas empreendedores né É só
que no fim das contas o que que
aconteceu então aconteceu o que o
empreendedor ele tem a sensação de
liberdade e ele tem o sensação de
proprietário quando o seu os donos do
negócio vocês quem coloca dinheiro
negócio que compra o que financia
intermediado por fundos de investimentos
podem ser mais ou menos neutros são os
mesmos donos de sempre tão no fim das
contas você só trocou o seu arranjo
trabalhista né o Executivo só trocou o
arranjo trabalhista para se tornar
o empreendedor numa equação numa conta
numa paridade no equilíbrio que faz mais
sentido por dono para o investidor no
que para o empreendedor E pior do que
isso muitas vezes ao receber
investimento no Startup ela começa a
sofrer problemas de governança por quê
Porque o empreendedor passa a trabalhar
para entender para atender
especificamente o interesse dos seus
investidores e dos seus acionistas estão
nem sempre atender os interesses da
própria empresa muito menos dos clientes
dessa empresa isso não é
e essa relação ela também cidade uma
forma em que ela reforça uma série de
vícios né é quem pode dizer que
investidores e apostam e empreendedores
que se parecem com eles próprios
e o que seja um processo projeções deles
próprios existe mundo isomorfismo
normativo que é se você fizer um raio-x
das principais Startup investidas no
Brasil Oi você vai ver que os
empreendedores que receberam a pote ele
se parece muito mais como os seus
investidores do que com a classe
trabalhadora é E aí eu não tenho nada de
Comunismo e fundido correntes políticas
Não é isso não é disso que eu tô falando
nada conta né favor né isso tô falando
que existe uma tendência e um viés a
reforçar que o ecossistema que cada vez
mais dessa forma e por mais que você
tenha iniciativas de diversidade de
trazer para as mulheres empreendendo as
mulheres lideranças é se a fonte do
dinheiro do financiamento do negócio
escolhe sempre seguindo o mesmo padrão é
meio
Ah pára né essa essa essa Cultura né e é
curioso a gente reparar também na seita
aqui né no uma toda construção
ideológica que existe do ecossistema
descartáveis né isso vira uma moda né E
essa moda ela gera uma série de estar tá
Perus né Eu costumo dizer que os estar
tá Perus Você sabe quando uma não
ficarem sem nós para tirar um
empreendedor ele demora se não é não é
uma relação muito proporcional porque a
coisa assim descer mim né é que centenas
de pessoas é o talento de uma geração e
eu posso dizer que as status primeiros
reduziram as gerações um pouco mais
jovens e aí hoje você já tem um livro de
ser realidade diferente você viu
envolvido nesse meio né profissionais
migrando de negócios corporativos para
status porque um lugar que te entrega
pertencimento entre
e regalias advertido gostoso ambiente é
ótimo tem cerveja tem jogo tem tem uma
cultura mais fluida mais adaptada tem
uma cultura que é tão boa quanto todos
os meus amigos ou melhor em uma um
ambiente que é tão bom quanto da minha
casa ou muitas vezes melhor do que da
minha casa e isso faz com que a gente
tenha toda uma geração é trabalhando e
ficando no trabalho muito mais tempo né
para receber inclusive menos do que
receberiam uma posição corporativa de
uma empresa padrão agora se você parar
para pensar olha os status mais famosas
que você conhece né no Brasil é E aí
pensa no problema só problema que essas
está faz estão resolvendo né ou com a
problema que essas empresas estão
resolvendo né Já fiz minha dor em vários
problemas de tártaro
E aí hoje porque assim o que de fato
essa turma está produzindo né porque
quando a gente pensa nos grandes
problemas da humanidade grandes
problemas da nossa sociedade dentro
problemas dos nossos serviços urbanos né
raríssimos os casos em que esses
empreendedores eles estão pensando em
uma geração de valor do mundo né E aí eu
não tô falando de empreendedorismo
social tá eu não tô falando de
filantropia tá eu tô falando de criar
modelos de negócio que não seja de uma
mera entrega de conveniência para uma
classe consumidora né é boa parte dessas
statapes com mais estejam empresas
incríveis e eu jamais desejaria isso
esse deixar você desistir amanhã não
farei falta para ninguém a não ser claro
pelos empregos mas assim é
e parece um pouco desafiador a gente ter
todo o capital intelectual né é dedicado
a entregar conveniência a uma classe
consumidora será que é isso que a gente
espera e queda dos nossos principais
talentos é será que os nossos talentos
Talvez um deles não está mais dedicados
a resolver Grandes Questões humanas e
criando inclusive grande ótimos modelos
negócio para resolver essas questões né
a bandeirinha deixou claro para gente
uma série de superficialidades né e uma
série de caps que a tecnologia ainda nos
traz né sem seguir o dinheiro a gente
vai entender que os investidores é que
os donos dos negócios acionis eles
também tem um mecanismo de incentivo e
reconhecimento que não busca o maior
valor é
e o apanhou a geração de impacto para a
humanidade né ele busca maior retorno
pelo investimento
o ponto de será que será métrica que a
gente quer os negócios é será que é
desse empreendedorismo do jeito que está
hoje que a gente realmente preciso